توقعات او تنبؤات او ربما تكون امنيات تلك
التي اطلقها الرئيس السابق ونائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي دي ماتري مدفادف للعام
23 23 لعب مدفادف دور شخصيه راس بوتين
التاريخيه من هو شخصيه روسيه مثيره للجدل
كان راهبا امنيا واعتبره الكثير من الناس
قديسا وبعض افراد عائله القيصر وكان منجما
يزعم التنبؤ بالمستقبل لن اعود الى توقعات
التي حملت عناوين عريضه بعيده عن الواقع
باكثر المصطلحات الماسيه على الاقل
التي توقع لها حربا اهليه تفضي الى انفصال
كاليفورنيا وتكساس
ولليورو الانهيار ولد ولا الاتحاد
الاوروبي التفكك وتحول اسواق المال
العالميه من امريكا واوروبا الى اسيا
توقعات اقرب الى التمنيات ربما
للرئيس الروسي السابق وربما الحالي
على تويتر زياده اسعار النفط الى 150
دولارا للبرميل واسعار الغاز الى خمسه
الاف دولار لكل الف متر مكعب
استيلاء بولندا والمجر على المناطق
الغربيه من اوكرانيا السابقه بحسب وصفه من
اوكرانيا السابقه
ثم انشاء الرايخ الرابع في المانيا
يعقبهم دلاع الحرب بين فرنسا والريخ
الرابع وتقسيم اوروبا
كما لم تسلم ايرلندا الشماليه من تنبؤات
العراف مدفادف التي توقع انفصالها عن
بريطانيا التي ستعود للاتحاد الاوروبي كما
توقع قبل ان ينقسم بدوره
الملياردير الامريكيه ايلون ماسك كان له
نصيبه من توقعات حالف بوتين اذ توقع
انتصار ماسك في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في بعض الولايات المخصصه
للجمهوريين لكن متى بعد الحرب الاهليه
التي توقعها
ماسك رد سريعا بتهكما واضح ووصف توقعات
الرئيس الروسي السابق بانها سخيفه وقال
مالك تويتر الجديده هذه بالتاكيد اكثر
التنبؤات سخافه سمعتها على الاطلاق والتي
تظهر نقصا نقصا مذهلا في الوعي بتقدم ذكاء
الاصطناعي والطاقه المستدامه
كريستي كريستي
[موسيقى]
تكنولوجيا سوريا
كنت
ساكن